die zentrale von volkswagen financial
services in braunschweig
ich stehe hier wo ihrem gebäude und wir
würden gerne wissen ob ihr unternehmen
in indien bestechung von ministern
finanziert der pressesprecher ist in der
leitung
es gibt kein interview
[Musik]
die recherchen beginnen vor mehr als
einem jahr
frontal21 werden dokumente zugespielt
ein interner ermittlungsbericht aus dem
volkswagen-konzern
es geht um die vw-tochter firma scania
die habe in indien einen ganz besonderen
bus fertigen lassen berichten die
internen ermittler
der bus war bestimmt für die hochzeit
von frau gaga keri der tochter von nitin
got car meeting guide kari ist nicht
irgendwer er ist einer der mächtigsten
indischen politiker und verkehrsminister
auf facebook finden wir ein foto von
berry in einem solchen luxus airbus ist
eine sonderanfertigung mit liege sitzen
aus leder und tv großbildschirmen
in den dokumenten die kalkulierten
kosten für das luxus klo umgerechnet
20.000 euro im detail abgesprochen mit
einem der söhne von minister karl
korruption einer volkswagen tochter in
indien offiziell verkauft scania den
luxus an einen vertriebspartner
der vermieteten bus weiter an eine
andere firma die dem ministerrat kg
nahesteht
finanziert wird der luxusbus von
volkswagen finance mit einem kredit als
die ratenzahlungen ausbleiben holt sich
die eine vw-tochter das geld von der
anderen vw tochter scania 260.000 euro
denn scania hatte für den kredit zu 100%
gebürgt und zum schluss ist der bus beim
minister und scania hat bezahlt war also
der bus ein geschenk an den minister um
geschäfte zu machen also bestechung mit
hilfe der volkswagen finanzfirma
volkswagen erklärt diesen vorwurf weist
die volkswagen financial services
private limited in japan sich die
internen ermittler von volkswagen sehen
das anders
laut untersuchungsbericht soll die vw
finanztochter gewusst haben worum es
ging
laut einschätzung von quellen bei
volkswagen financial services war der
bus ein geschenk mit dem zweck den
zuschlag für geschäfte in indien zu
bekommen
die angelegenheit mit dem minister bus
ist für mich ein exemplarisches beispiel
jetzt in anführungszeichen gesprochen
geschick der korruption und in gewisser
weise ist das ja fast noch
problematischer als die offene
bestechung
denn man versucht eben alles zu tun dass
das nicht bekannt werden kann
verabredung mit ma lin mendl im
vergangenen frühjahr
sie ist korrespondentin des schwedischen
fernsehens
scania hat seinen sitz in schweden der
vw konzern in deutschland ab jetzt
recherchieren wir gemeinsam
in indien gehen mal in mandel und ihr
team einem weiteren korruptionsfall nach
in einer kohlemine einer staatlichen
minengesellschaft die hat 100 scania
kipplaster gekauft die polizei ermittle
seit jahren weil dafür bestechungsgeld
geflossen sein soll
nachfrage bahnchef terminen gesellschaft
lasst die untersuchung mal weitergehen
die wahrheit wird kommen jetzt bitte nur
noch fragen zu anderen themen wenn sie
welche haben die internen vw ermittler
stoßen auf etwas anderes betrug bei der
ausschreibung
denn die geforderten kipplaster vom typ
p 380 konnte die vw tochter scania nicht
liefern nur laster vom typ b 410 die
ermittler stellen fest scania india hat
absichtlich und betrügerisch 100 scania
b 410 kipplaster verändert um sie als
café 380 kipplaster auszugeben
nur so konnte die vw tochter die
ausschreibung gewinnen
dafür hat scania diese fahrzeugpapiere
und zertifikate gefälscht die ermittler
urteilen
betrügerische falschdarstellung von
fahrzeugen betrügerische veränderung von
fahrzeugen betrügerische änderung der
fahrzeugdokumente nicht nur
fahrzeugdokumente mussten gefälscht
werden sondern auch die typ schilder in
den scania laster bangalore in indien
mal in mendel findet hier die firma die
die gefälschten typ schilder hergestellt
hat in deren computer ist sowohl die
scania rechnung als auch die schilder
vorlage für die gefälschten kipplaster
gespeichert der chef erinnert sich dass
die schilder nicht so scania fabrik
sondern zur privatadresse des scania
manager ausgeliefert worden
und es wird noch absurder die
typenschilder der fabrikneuen laster
mussten getauscht werden
aber nicht etwa bei scania sondern hier
auf einer hühnerfarm der pharma zeigt
den ort zwischen zwei hühner stellen
wollen den schweren scania kipplaster an
herumgeschraubt wurde täglich fünf bis
sechs fahrzeuge und warum wollten sie
diesen platz zum verstecken
damit kann er sieht 100 kipplaster
wurden hier umdeklariert sie sind rein
haben die typische da weggemacht durch
neue typ schilder ersetzt und sie wieder
raus volkswagen räumt die fälschungen
ein sieht aber darin keinen betrug
schließlich sei kein schaden entstanden
die kohle firma wurde bis heute nicht
informiert auch nicht die versicherung
der kipplaster
dabei stellen die internen ermittler von
volkswagen fest es gab eine reihe von
unfällen im ersten versicherungsjahr für
die die versicherungen bezahlt hat
volkswagen sieht darin keinen
versicherungsbetrug und erklärt zu den
lastern erstaunliches die
modellbezeichnung ist im hinblick auf
die versicherung keine wesentliche
information
jeder weiß dass das in aller regel bei
einzelkunden zum verlust des
versicherungsschutzes führt wenn
volkswagen die papiere der lastwagen
gefälscht hat weil sie andere fahrzeuge
geliefert haben als ausgeschrieben waren
dann ist es auch der versicherung
gegenüber nicht nur zu melden sondern
eventuell auch dort ein straftatbestand
der erfüllt ist auch das indische
busgeschäft von scania sollte mit
schmiergeldern angeheizt werden weil die
meisten busse hier im besitz staatlicher
gesellschaften sind muss die vw-tochter
beamte sogar minister bestechen damit
die für umsatz sorgen
die ermittler fanden fotos von einer
solchen bestechung
das geld wird in einer schwarzen
plastiktüte übergeben der frau eines
weiteren ministers
der kurier schickt ein foto an den
scania manager
[Musik]
wie soll das foto teamarbeit
hahaha aber nicht darüber reden oder
benutzen
ja ist nur für unsere sicherheit ok klar
die internen vw ermittlungsakten nennen
weitere schmiergeld fälle bei scania in
indien mindestens sechs staatliche
transportfirmen wurden demnach bestochen
doch nur einer korruptions spur durften
die ermittler folgen anweisung von oben
von einem steuerungskomitee darauf
weisen die ermittler in ihrem bericht
ausdrücklich hin
der steuerungskomitee folgt der logik
möglichst nur das aufdecken zu lassen
was unvermeidbar ist dabei werden auch
schuldige benannt
aber der ganze sumpf sag ich jetzt mal
drum herum wird ausgespart
und das ist für ein weltunternehmen
heute zu wenig henriksson ist chef der
vw tochter scania
er hat aus steuerungskomitee eingesetzt
und geleitet rechtfertigungsversuche
wie wir im winter gern mal haben wir
versuchen da nicht irgendwas zu
verbergen
wir wollen wirklich der sache auf den
grund gehen was mich dabei richtig
ärgert wenn ich sehe was da in indien
passiert ist ist dass einige wenige
personen in indien sachen gemacht haben
die man nicht tun darf und damit schaden
sie fast 50.000 mitarbeitern bei scania
die so ein verhalten absolut nicht
akzeptieren und das macht mich total
sauer
nun hat der scania bros angekündigt den
vw-konzern zu verlassen das habe nichts
mit der korruption in indien zu tun
sein nachfolger wird christian levin
hier rechts im bild neben
verkehrsminister guard kari
scania habe in indien die konsequenzen
gezogen und baut dort keine busse mehr
für den volkswagen-konzern ist die sache
erledigt scania hat dieses fehlverhalten
konsequent abgestellt betroffene
mitarbeiter und manager gekündigt sowie
vertragsbeziehungen mit betroffenen
geschäftspartnern beendet also alles
erledigt trotz hochzeitskuss für
minister gefälschten lkw und
plastiktüten voller schmiergeld in
deutschland wird sich jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft braunschweig mit den
vorwürfen befassen
wir werden aufgrund der recherchen von
frontal 21 vor ermittlungen einleiten
das heißt wir werden prüfen ob als ob es
anhaltspunkte für ein strafrechtliches
verhalten gibt sollte dies der fall sein
werden sich echte ermittlungen
anschließen
echte ermittlungen aber sind nur gegen
personen möglich topmanager der vw
tochter financial services an korruption
beteiligt waren muss die
staatsanwaltschaft klären
gegen das unternehmen selbst können sie
nicht ermitteln im moment ist es so dass
es ein unternehmens strafrecht hat
solches nicht gibt das heißt
ermittlungen gegen ein unternehmen sind
nicht möglich wir können nur ermitteln
wenn es straftaten deutscher straftaten
zum nachteil deutscher oder straftaten
in deutschland gibt nur da können wir
tatsächlich ermittlungen einleiten
ansonsten sind uns die hände gebunden
und das ist die große gruppe in
deutschland das es eben kein
unternehmens strafrecht gibt anders als
in den usa in frankreich in holland also
in eigentlich den allermeisten
westlichen demokratien
und so kommt es dass der vw-konzern in
deutschland nicht zur verantwortung
gezogen werden kann
für korruption und betrug in indien
[Musik]